the state is showing you how to play  when you have the threat of making  threes what do you do  exactly what he's doing right here  attack the cup  damien lee scores on doncic  damien lee aggressive from the start  taking  all kind of contact and gets the foul  here  from the wise philosopher curtis blow  basketball is my favorite sport i love  the way they dribble up and down the  court and it's because  of smart play don't just play the  numbers of analytics  you play game and right there  lee knows he has game scoring one inside  and that's what you want to do to make  the lead and if you're dallas right now  you're playing well but you must be  careful these last two minutes because  you'll believe that you're a better  three